Westport Connecticut is a place that she
does not fit in and she does not want to
fit it it could be any wealthy community
that this family has moved into
principally for the schools it's a nice
town very high-end a lot of skinny
people but also it's a very cliquey town
okay they have the moms that are always
in activewear but not necessarily active
and drinking the healthy green juices
and go into yoga and none of us do that
who came up with the idea that a mother
of three should have an ass like a 19
year old oh you have a great ass Katie
thank you I know it is really outspoken
and a very strong strong woman pretty
much wants to have sex with me all the
time anyway and says things that polite
society frowns upon and in polite
society at all society you know I love
the way you look I hate something weird
she is an authentic lady living in an
inauthentic world and she's sassy and
she's a firecracker and she says
effective you'll deflate
it's my Spanx maybe is kind of mom who
world just like fight until all of her
teeth are gone for her kids is that one
of those green healthy drinks yeah but
she will also fight her kids I will not
have that in this house
dad I'll leave you to handle this okay
I'm just gonna relocated for you
something natal we've all got a Westport
Connecticut no matter from Iowa or Miami
board Wichita everybody has their
situation but they just don't feel like
the fitting in
I think stepping into a really bright
spotlight I want women to feel like
they're being seen and understood that
it's okay that they're not perfect
that's making me feel really bad about
something that I don't already feel
great about in the first place
being fat this is the part where you say
I'm not fat you're not fat
it is truly about walking through the
fire C unit knowing that you're not
perfect it's gonna be okay to Mars a new
day and you're gonna come out on the
other end
you